hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I finally am getting back into the
white night which has taken me much
longer than I had anticipated but I am
very happy to be back I'm just starting
to redownload all my files I think I got
to generally the same place that I was
I'm except for getting these morphine
out of the walls here and someone said
that I need to take a better look at
this dead guy okay I'm getting a Rio
it's a dead lady oh oh oh okay yeah that
was a dead lady I didn't even notice
that was a lady before us okay now I can
start making progress so I'm picking up
exactly where I left off
thank goodness man it's been too long
since I played in Asia it's weird I've
been playing it almost uh every other
day at the bare minimum for the past few
months to be away from it for as long as
I have just now it's kind of a shock so
anyway I'm happy to bring this to you
guys I'm sorry I apologize there's
plenty of time to be creepy in here hang
on wait I got to do something I think I
might have forgot it's little bit dark
cooped up so you guys need to be able to
see it's also a little bit loud so you
guys need to be able to hear hearing and
seeing are two important things for
human beings I mean ask you o us humans
I picked up a light bulb I don't even
have a flashlight it's really dark I
can't I can't I cannot see anything I do
not know what's in front of me okay so a
light went out I can't even see where on
the walls I would need to put that on
there it is like really dark I don't
know why I may need to crank up the
brightness just a bit more no no I was
just supposed to be dark nevermind there
it doesn't seem like there's a mechanic
where your eyes adjust to that darkness
Oh get away no not today
ah no ah ah screw you go you screw you
screw off ah Wow
oh it just collapse well that killed you
dick my name you dick
Richard MacFarlane ten real more like
Richard mcfar ting ting ha ha ha I'm so
clever and smart and handsome oh come on
ok Lowe's deal with that why didn't I
need to go up all that way if I was just
gonna get stuck at the top anyway let me
know your secrets what the hell was that
what was that I could really use a
flashlight what did the thing get killed
under those rocks I didn't see anything
hanging let me let me double check just
to be sure I always like to be thorough
as opposed to just wandering around for
10 hours when I should have gone back a
bit nope
I see nothing carrying on moving forward
moving downwards specifically but also
in a forwardly direction okay what was
the point of all that did I need to pick
up a key somewhere cuz I really can't
see anything I don't know see can't get
in there can't get in there alright I'm
gonna crank up the brightness just a bit
more because this is obscenely dark and
I'm sure that you guys can't see a thing
if I'm recording this I okay so what do
we got here what is this what is this
what is what what what is that what is
that what are you what is going on why
can't I see anything fights grit ma oh
my god still can't see [ __ ] okay so it's
not just me it's actually there's
literally no light here sorry about that
yep that'll do okay so now that that
little escapade is over I need to figure
out what aha what done oh shut up Wade
God it called me right as I'm recording
whadda ya wanna deck Wade I hope you see
this cuz then you know you don't goof ah
okay so I I don't know I don't know I
really don't know I'm I can't go back
there is a door over here but I can't
open it without like don't have a key
so I need a tool which is obviously not
back here cuz I can't see any ten I
can't see and at ten guys I want to know
what that sound is first off but that
guy is also bleeding profusely I don't
know I I really just don't know I was
supposed I went up here I looked I did
not see anything in the rubble that
crushed the monster whatever was chasing
me wait what that what the oh ah I can't
pull it out by hand what the hell how
did that get stuck in there but what is
that it stuck into the wall how did it
get stuck how huh that is my question
how did that happen what da hell is
going on I I need like a rock to throw
at it I don't know
yeah maybe let's try that let's try that
yeah when in doubt my oldest amnesia
rule when in doubt throw a rock at it
yeah yeah that was a crowbar I did not
look like a crowbar alright whatever
game logic I will let game logic be game
logic and I'll just carry on my way yeah
Wow Wow oh sorry I gotta let the crazy
out a little too much and then it just
goes out of control and takes me over
huh okay let's wrap up look look I can't
even see where the crowbar is if the
crowbar is in this door I cannot see it
gimme that didn't get it can I use a
sight in this way you're kidding me
Wowz it's prolly for the door the top
balls
ah okay all right we're alive come on
work damn you Wow
I'm gonna go our stick crazy hi what da
hell
seriously what da helling hell what
effing eff is going to f on and hear
what the troll game is trying to make me
look like an idiot which I do on a daily
basis I don't need your help game trying
to make me look bad
trying to make all my friends think I'm
an idiot that's Wade's fall he called me
and threw me off my game here I was
totally gonna get it didn't a light
break or something can I replace a light
get some gosh turn light up in yah
cannot use this item this way that
uh-huh then what do i do what do i do
I'm turning the brightness back up screw
it screw it screw it screw it yeah that
looks good
anything on the walls what about here
guess I'm film noir atmosphere going up
on this [ __ ] gah I'm gonna OH
what is this what are you what what have
I got what am i holding on to what am i
trying to move here what was that what
was that what what what oh hey what are
you what are you pitch blackness thing
pitch blackness device what are you oh
wait what ah ah oh oh you oh you oh you
son of a [ __ ] oh you motherf er if you
all couldn't see what happened the
crowbar was actually
in the door but he was still in my
inventory so I couldn't tell that it was
in the door ah god this guy oh and this
is a good custom story oh is it is it
really oh god oh god oh yeah did I
forget to pick up a flashlight or
something is that what happened is that
what's going on here how am I supposed
to be able to see things and yet they're
not I can understand everything up until
that little area with the pitch-black no
seeing this because that's not fun that
is not happy fun times I am a grumpy
markiplier right now I am grumpy my
grump is in the extreme levels what
happened I'm tied to a table now I look
good bring it on [ __ ] dip it dr. Pryor
out to harvest my organs suck my kidneys
draw straw
okay what was that I would like to know
what the hell was that what ah bollocks
I would love a flat oh okay okay that's
good never mind sorry
remember how you forgot everything
remember who you are you have to try
harder David or we will perish okay so
this room is kind of wonky these doors
are kind of locked it whoo hello what
the hell is going on there okay I'm
sorry I got grumpy this is a good custom
story I just got a little grumpy
they couldn't what ha ha ha oh this is
cool now this is why it's a good amnesia
custom Jory because there are cool stuff
like this ha ha whoa oh man it sound
like a skull in blood I'm seeing that it
looks like a face in the distance there
I'm not sure I might be wrong maybe I
can see through this door hello oh no
it's just a bunch of cloud blood hello
what have we got a burning vending
machine no not the Saudi pop aah people
apparently don't like it when I say the
words sody pop but uh that's what it's
called no screw you [ __ ] I think you
shocked me electroshock therapy my ass
get out of here
anyway see the boxes vent say what huh I
need a box where do I get a box there's
the box here I don't see a box Brougham
I see no box can I rip that off the wall
maybe oh there were bucks oh come on
there were boxes way over there oh
you're kidding me you're such an [ __ ]
game you're shy not at all hello
the game itself is really cool because
there's a lot of interesting stuff going
on but the game mechanics and choices of
the game designer are questionable at
best yeah unless there was a secret
super secret box maybe nope uh-uh this
is the way it be this is they don't
think you'd be like it is but it do now
as I carry on with my box the weight of
the world rests on my shoulders and I
feel nothing okay hi this kinda reminds
me of cry of fear in a lot of ways I
mean crazy mental murdering guy mental
hospital all that jazz oh my or jumping
puzzle holy crap I'm gonna die I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die no I'm not gonna die
I'm a winner I'm a winner I'm a
thoroughbred winning douche nozzle hop
flap right rah-rah-rah
ha ha ha what was that flowing on the
ground there I'm not sure ha ha now ok
that was cool I don't mean to be overly
critical a bitter taste in my mouth the
pain in my temple my mind does not
remember but my body does have I done
something to deserve this that's the
question I should answer that's the
thing I need to remember I don't mean to
be overly critical about this game it is
good good custom story I can tell a lot
of work was put into this there's a lot
of interesting mechanics and stuff like
that I am
not saying it's a bad in any way I like
it I just got stuck in a different area
she's got stuck in a stupid area but I'm
okay okay looky hey I still haven't gone
through this door haha
okay now I'm through the door okay that
door closed
give me your soda pop I'm so thirsty we
are under complete overhaul all of the
old furnitures and stuffs are being
replaced dr. s is very strict about her
instructions well I don't mind those old
rotting wood beds are being replaced by
the new strong iron ones I'm tired of
chinches already what I don't understand
is while they're placing electrical gay
electronic gate to isolated patients
ward why they wanted me to keep the ward
door locked probably because they didn't
want the crazy patients to get out
you're not a very smart maintenance man
are is you maybe the crowbar would help
okie dokie whatever you say Wow
screw dry for why do as I need a
screwdriver what I need is a flasher
light a flash Oh lighting device a flash
Oh light 9000 oh right I'm actually all
out of time for now so I'm just gonna
have to pause here thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye